mais en fait ces gens là ils ont fait
quoi ils ont fait rien en fait leur
qualité cette critique et les gens qui
ont envie de se faire une situation où
se lever au matin et se battre des gens
un peu comme ce petit gros la non non
non non
juste une grosse queue
[Applaudissements]
abdallah saleh comme du salat et
honnêtement je vais dire exactement ce
que je t'aurais dit ce n'est pas là moi
j'ai un malaise quand je te vois
globalement tu sais c'est le même effet
que quand je vois loana sur les plateaux
télé pardon je te compare pas loana
c'est qu'à un moment donné à traiter un
petit bourgeois et un petit bourgeois
c'est grâce à de longues du loft et la
célébrité jacques choisit maintenant
mais coûte 13 ans et j'étais donc en
fait il doit répondre il aurait voulu un
candidat chez toi je ne parle pas aux
ânes ça les instruit
je parle de toi chaîne atb atteint bbbb
écoute là et comment ça pas méchant
c'est vrai mais non là c'est méchant
écoutez vous écouter vous mais je les
écoute magistrat crime meriem une jambe
peut pas y penser mais disputée avec toi
ça le problème c'est normal vous n'allez
pas brillant voyant leur écoute a plus
d'argent qui sont autour de nous
ici mais aucun des gens regardent
car est un raccourci n'est pas tout le
monde s'en fout ta tête bon ben on
arrête d'en parler un gentil c'est déjà
ma fille d'un juger les gens à ouidah
l'agent quel est ton sortir mais très
rapide à semaine à la fille d'attenté la
côte de clémence et moi et moi et moi à
merde s'il te plaît on peut écouter on
peut s'écouter écoute qu'il a à dire et
après tu réponds je n'ai même mois ils
m'intéressent ça dérange pas une
reddition mais c'est pas besnehard je
m'en fous
il écoute le n'est pas dans le
figaro nino
aulas stérile puisque
non s'il te plaît de terminer nous dira
si l'on tape lurel a dirigé le meilleur
est franchement dans les yeux on jeudi
globalement ce que beaucoup 90% mais j'y
pense de toi et deuxièmement il est
fait quoi toi dans ta jour de la finale
belle mère
chérie fida tu te grandirais en battant
moins vulgaire en étant plus respectueux
[Applaudissements]
oui mais mon coeur mon coeur pour rappel
on rappelle parce qu'il rappelle que la
pièce a été un succès pendant quatre
semaines et ont dit être engagés mardi à
mercredi la semaine prochaine au théâtre
habilité à semelle tout c'est quoi oui
et tu sais quoi et guillaume et moi et
guillemet moratoire de beaucoup plaisir
et non mais moi aussi aussi mais là
maintenant il faut que tu te calmes un
tout petit peu parce que là je sens
qu'il ya un petit peu calmé je veux
adresser la java bleue puissant que
personne à tous tout proche me financés
par des gens qui tout à fait